the modern warfare series has always
been about the messiness of modern war
the fundamentally different rules of
engagement that come with a battle that
has no set battlefields when the fight
could be anywhere at any time where do
you draw the line between doing what's
right and doing what has to be done
throughout call of duty modern warfare
campaign that line is chemical weapons
it's a safe line to draw people are
largely in agreement that chemical
weapons are beyond horrific but there
are other horrors of war some of which
modern warfare depicts starkly and
strong but uncomfortable missions just
when it could really make a point about
any other aspect of modern war it pulls
back
modern warfare makes old observations
and presents them with new flourishes
those new flourishes do make for a good
campaign and solid multiplayer but is
when modern warfare asks you to think
harder that it falls short
in one of the game's most distressing
levels you play as Farah
a young girl in a fictional war-torn
Middle Eastern country as she hides from
both a Russian terrorist and the deadly
gas his cohorts have been leashed on her
town to escape you have to kill a man
twice your size with his own gun
it's a deeply uncomfortable experience
but the flashback serves to illustrate
why Farah now the leader of a group of
freedom fighters refuses to use chemical
weapons or associate with anyone who
does it is a hard line she won't cross
even though she's had to face a lot of
ugliness in the course of defending her
country in many ways Farah is Modern
Warfare's moral compass there are a few
key players in Modern Warfare's proxy
war and everyone you play as sergeant
Kyle Garrick from the UK rogue American
soldier Alex echo 3-1 and sometimes
Farah herself abides by her one rule
outside of that though the rules are
much murkier in getting pulled into a
war between the Russian terrorists a
separatist group from Forrest country
and the freedom fighters themselves US
and UK military personnel disagree on
how to best proceed with the situation
matters of disobeying orders sacrificing
some life to save others taking civilian
hostages and even torture and on these
matters the moral compass is Captain
Price
a returning face from the original
modern warfare and undeniably a
problematic fave captain price is the
seasoned badass who takes the lead in
most Garrick missions early levels with
price are among the best they range from
large-scale high-octane firefights to a
carefully planned raid on a terrorist
hideout with less than a dozen enemies
total price guides you through the
different approaches you need for each
mission and his mentorship both in the
mechanical skills you need to be
successful and the hard choices you have
to make along the way makes these
missions memorable while Alex's missions
don't stick out quite as much in a
gameplay sense he gets a sniping level
reminiscent of the original Modern
Warfare's all Gallade up but with more
enemies and otherwise a few cool gadgets
his dynamic was farah is strong though
he follows far as lead on her turf and
on her terms because he believes in the
cause and they share mutual respect it's
disappointing though that Farah doesn't
play more of a role while she is a key
part of Alex's missions and the driving
force behind much of the story he only
plays her a few times on top of the
childhood flashback there is an even
more disturbing flashback later on in
which you see the full extent of fires
resolve experiencing her suffering this
way borders on unnecessary and it's
already established in Alex's missions
that she's a respected leader and a
strong-willed person in general while I
liked Alex I would have rather just
played as Farah in those missions then
get to know her character largely
through her trauma while modern warfare
raises difficult questions in the end it
fails to interrogate them further all
you get is a vague we all did what we
had to do sentiment rather than anything
more substantial or interesting the
ending isn't bad but it is a safe one
leaving you to think on the harder
questions for yourself why if we got our
hands tied
just take the bloody gloves off a fight
if anything modernwarfare let's fara
down with the bizarre and much-discussed
inclusion of white phosphorus as a
killstreak in multiplayer given how
strong the campaign's emphasis is on
chemical weapons being a reprehensible
war crime it's tone-deaf to include one
in multiplayer
[Music]
outside of any somatic contradictions
Modern Warfare's multiplayer is up to
par with a variety of game types for
different kinds of players realism mode
is undeniably the highlight it's
somewhere between the familiar core and
hardcore modes bridging the gap between
them oddly enough you can take more
damage than in hardcore and your health
regenerates like a dozen core but
realism removes the hood entirely going
beyond hardcore to strip out the kill
feed on top of everything else in order
to confirm a kill you have to listen for
the sound effect that plays upon death
it's a fantastic balance for those who
want more of a chance to survive a scrap
rather than dying in one or two shots
like in hardcore but with the rest of
the challenge intact it's a smart
satisfying evolution and there's a
stubborn hardcore only player it's one I
could see myself playing exclusively
going forward while none of the new game
types are earth-shattering some are
better editions than others TDM 2810 v10
version of the classic six v6 team
deathmatch mode is the least inventive
or warranted of them instead functioning
as a more bloated version of regular TDM
with bigger maps that can make getting
back into the action in overly long
process one of the two maps I've tried
Euphrates bridge also suffers from
balance problems on top of that of the
two spawns one is much closer to the
bridge dividing the map and the closer
side was almost guaranteed victory in
every match I played gunfight is the
antithesis of TDM 20 it's a 1 life 2 V 2
mode in which your loadout rotates each
round and the goal is to kill your two
opponents with the means available to
you before they get you first with a
relatively level playing field battles
are often exhilaratingly close and it's
hard to get discouraged by a loss since
rounds go by so quickly
ground war is somewhere in the middle
maps are sprawling with five control
points to capture in one safe zone for
each team on either end
unlike in TDM 20 you can pretty easily
get back to the fight after dying by
responding at any capture point your
team owns or on two vehicles for your
teammates provided they're not actively
in a fight
having objective points is also helpful
for keeping such a large game type more
structured than the free-for-all of TDM
that said matches can drag on a bit too
long as there isn't anything to break up
the constant tug-of-war for capture
points as of this writing spec UPS is
the mode I've had the least experience
with though it's not one I particularly
want to play much more of on paper it's
a co-op mode where you and a team
complete a set of objectives and are
rewarded with some story in practice my
team of four could fairly complete a
handful of the objectives on both of the
missions we attempted this was largely
due to frustrating enemy spawning
enemies seem to generate endlessly from
all directions and it's all too easy to
get overwhelmed by them to add insult to
injury there are also no clear waves
it's just enemies from everywhere at all
times we tried a few different
approaches on each of the two missions
to try to figure it out but no matter
what we did it didn't help our
understanding of the mode itself it's
just frustrating Lee inexplicably hard
that said I will be trying it again in
the coming days to see if there was
anything we were missing and I also have
to play the ps4 exclusive survival mode
the pitfalls of spec ops don't detract
from what modern warfare does well
realism mode is an excellent addition to
the slate and although not all the new
multiplayer modes are great gunfight is
a refreshing standout and while the
campaign ends up playing it safe in the
end it's still a memorable one and it
lays a strong foundation for where the
modern warfare series could go from here
and you keeping your word on I don't do
this to keep my word
[Music]
you